Highlanders start Horvat parel and hrom with
Thompson and pelic as the puck is down and we are
underway here this evening Clayton Keller with the
puck for the coyotes who are starting the season
on a 4 game Road Trip New Jersey the Rangers the
Islanders they'll hit the St Louis Blues on the
way back West as this Puck deflex out the center
bouncing Puck to schaltz touched it on for Keller
Keller pulls up at the dot throws it across to
a trailing Dumba and he put it off the post Matt
Dumba fifth guys will be joining the rush All
Night One flipped through the neutral zone Krauss
knocked it down bu stat stepped into a shot that's
gloved and held by sokin find their own identity
and he feels like this is a year where they they
can do that this one sna the net rolling P back
Deni the follow up from Paul maray net watch the
Islanders just jaming to the net Nelson First Paul
Mary and that's a good save good react no time
wasted for S baluk too that's what I want to
see quick decisions you got the puck right off his
stick and a good scoring opportunity that's one of
his assets that he does extremely well is that he
does get the shots through Thomas you would know
him better than me but that that's what I've seen
from him in the in a very obviously small sample
yeah he's a big man and he gets it off his stick
in a hurry nson and P three out two over the line
P Nelson shoot save rebound stop by Thea have
to kill penalty and Butch when the season starts
as good as it did for for Brock Nelson and Kyle
Paul Mary in game one game choices to make himona
defense were very tight to the middle of the ice
and Ang ball cutting down the far side yeah he was
wide open this one wrapped into the slot towards
Logan coing forced out the center by Carone Old
Duke ahead Martin didn't get a piece and if he
did he was on the wrong side of Center but cus
with a heads up hustle play beat out the icing and
nearly set up a goal for Cal Clutterbuck flutter
buuck working hard on carcone can't bring it to
the net carcone moves away from cik is McBain
off the glass and he'll get it out am miss the hit
from Matt Martin that pass was intended for barel
who turn the other way Arizona try to capitalize
sh dery with a good look knocked down by the glove
hand of sokin pressure will continue coie to dery
dersy from out high and it's into the glove of
soken gets a whistle with 57 seconds left on
the kill return to Thompson straightway Paul
Murray puts down the onetime steps in now shoots
save made rebound was loose stopped in the crease
and cleared by Travis durman on the power play
Sebastian AO the Ryan pull off takes the shot with
the tip from Anders Lee in front tried to bank
it in off the mea half forwards for Keller Keller
moving to the middle of the ice switch places with
valaki the drop pass Clutterbuck again no stick
couldn't do anything Keller across one timer over
top of the net good play by t uh didn't have a
shot on Nets so I said I'll do the next best thing
almost worked out well for him oh Mary saw famela
go down but the big 6'4 frame still covered the
top of the net from his knees I mean that that's
a tough way a really hard way to learn the to play
in the game survive in the game but he did it well
roock Nelson rebound that one just missed the
that is PA Mary pushed it wide in the back hand
and you you have to be better than that I mean
now you can make excuses or you can say well we
had chances not good enough you need to score you
need to be able to establish the play you need to
make the opposition play catch up hockey and too
many times last year they didn't they played well
yet at the end of the day they got behind in
the game all too often see if the Islanders can
pick up where they left offs of opportunities
and momentum from the first period as Barrett
haon whiffed on a shot with Noah dumpson right
there with him Keller moves it across they swing
it down for schaltz loose stick on the ice Adam
Kell without one a shot that's blocked down in
front Hatton shoveled it between his skates but
wide to the net good job by doson in front of the
net tying up Hayden that was an empty net for us
Aon hayon off for slashing doson barzel one timer
scores Matt barzel with the power play [Applause]
goal the faceof win for the Islanders and P baral
scores on the power play and he practices one
timer and he practices to get it up in the toy
department no adops is able to get it and barzel
has got it in the shooting Lane and he just lets
it go but you get rewarded when you practice
right y Thomas Hickey not exactly a laser but
it does the trick it doesn't really matter and
for Matt barzel he's so used to catching that
he's such a gifted passer he's used to finding a
Lane right away they do move the face off outside
the Zone after the conversation final 2 minutes of
the the period with the aers up want nothing the
only goal Matt barsel on the power play they've
limited the coyotes to seven total shots on goal
here in the hockey game so faras melli chips
to the middle of his own Zone and it's dery
going for escape John dery left the puck behind
and then drop the pass off it comes to Holstrom
barzel horat all coming with him barzel right
side hrom stop by Thea there Al the the option
there's the pass to the outside now go to the net
where zel's got his head up and you can see that
puck by the time it landed was inside the crease
does he get any part of it yeah he does but theel
comes across the stats you you need to see from
from him and he certainly is providing him and
we talked about him through training camp he the
same kind of effort the same kind of dedication
to wanting to be the best he can and he's been
prepared marel 51 points in 58 games games last
year and of course went down with the knee injury
that cost him the final 23 games of the regular
season came back for the playoff series against
Carolina barzel again with the buck his shot was
off skate and then Holstrom ties up along the
end boards with Keller trying to get his stick
free and does the pass was behind barzel comes
to pelic off his back foot fires glanced off the
Blocker of Thea over the glass and Bo obviously
disappointed that he couldn't continue because he
was being very very productive a Paso troubled
it to the front Lee couldn't reach it comes to
Michael carcone his passes behind ukat and
fashing CR all there it's fashing came away
with the puck quickly ahead for pageo lead to the
net pass connects Lee across for fashing it was
an escape so the rebound was there Paso pushed it
wide poo I think would had he had the opportunity
would have stopped Brendon but I think he was
going pretty quick and couldn't put the binders
on nice little tap there by bu stab but missed the
net he got him tight to sokan something the isers
pretty good at limiting chances as Krauss again
in a good scoring area of the ice but never got
the shot away lead of Pou after valaki fell down
P Save By valaki no penalty on the play leans into
his right so good pass by Lee now watch Pou he's
going to protect the puck going to lean to his
right protect yeah I guess no penalty there 35
seconds left melli ahead for kie Logan kie back
hands it over a chance for buat blocked by Romanov
this one sliding to the slot poked away and it's
Brock Nelson he lost the control of the puck but
he recovers to clear the Zone down to 18 seconds
left melli ahead for kie with 14 pushed down deep
into the corner with 10 Romanov swings it around
Keller chips it up Nelson gloves it down off the
glass not out 5 Seconds this time it get out of
the Zone thrown towards the net and wide Islanders
went at one nothing with a shut out from ilas sok